has anyone approached you about like a
malcolm in the middle reunion or like
agent cody banks 3 or anything like that
to be honest both um and they were
actually kind of real
like five years ago
pre anything
making a
re-emergence you know now i feel like
every show has come back sure like
people don't really care about shows
coming back right um we were talking
about it brian was leading it because he
wants to do it again and
um
we got everyone on board
except for one person
but
they i don't they want to make it a
movie and i don't fully understand it
but i'd be thrilled you know what i mean
because it'd be cool to kind of see
where malcolm and his family are
20 years later whatever it is
um but i don't know what's happened with
that i know brian's been writing a
script and stuff like that so we'll see
what happens there but then agent cody
banks mgm has maybe i'm not allowed to
say this i don't know but i'm saying
anyway mgm has two really cool ideas for
agent cody banks
one
is like a
bojack horseman
type
cartoon of agent cody banks like what
happens when you're watching well you've
saved the world as a kid like and you
can't better than what i mean like and
just down on it like you know oh we can
call james bond uh he's busy i guess
call cody you know he's the last resort
you know fat dad you know now amazing i
think it'd be hilarious really yeah
agent cody banks if you guys don't know
it was like a teenage special agent
movies that i think i watched in my 30s
okay
i'm down for that [ __ ] yeah but that's
funny yeah the cool thing now is like
you know the kids who watched it in 2003
are
25 30 years old you know who who would
be into that type of thing right so uh
they've come to me with that which like
i said
maybe maybe me bringing it up will light
the fire yeah i think it'd be a really
fun idea i think it's hilarious and then
they have another idea for it's still
being like a kids thing where i'm like
cody banks
teaching the new crop of uh teenage buys
what was the one that's uh in the taylor
shop and it's like
oh uh uh kingsman the kings are now
those movies are really cool yeah so you
would be like a kingsman type like
training train like the young yeah you
like the kingsman
i mean we wouldn't watch it i i really
like those
i like all those kind of movies i think
movies in general just like
i can only suspend so much disbelief you
know like before i start thinking okay
this is just i'm not usually into like
the big crazy action movies like i i
mean to be honest i've never seen any of
the marvel movies i can't i can't get
through marvel but
like kingsman i i really really enjoyed
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com
and check out my tour schedule hurry up
and get your tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude